[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du vip aujourd'hui nous allons
parler musique et festivités vous l'avez
vu les beaux jours reviennent et pour
l'occasion un événement le samedi 21 mai
dans ce très beau lieu où l'on se trouve
aujourd'hui les étangs de hollande qui
se trouve dans la au coeur de la forêt
de rambouillet a bréviaire alors 400
phare pour venir jouer ici même et je
retrouve sidonie diaz bonjour bonjour et
elio d'abbas bonjour donc vous êtes
coordinatrice du centre culturel du
bourg situé à granby niveau est en stage
à l'usiné à chapeaux c'est bien ça mais
tout a un peu cher prenez le projet donc
déjà qu'est ce que vous pouvez me dire
que cet événement est ce qu'on peut me
le présenter un petit peu en quelques
mots il s'agit d'un festival de fanfares
et qui a la particularité d'être
organisé par trois structures
culturelles du sud-yvelines donc l'usiné
à chapeaux qui est un centre social une
maison des jeunes et de la culture et
une scène conventionnée de musique le
lieu peut-être tu peux présenter qui en
espace de création artistique on
accueille des compagnies artistiques en
résidence en particulier des compagnies
autour de l'espace public et la
barbacane qu'est le théâtre municipal de
ben alors c'est toi du coup qui a lieu
le 21 mai de 15 heures à 21 heures il
nous accueille au cat farc ont mal
accueilli
aussi tout au long de l'année dans ma
structure qui sont venus répéter dans
nos structures culturelles donc on a eu
l'occasion de connaître et qu on la
combat programmé pour cet pour cette
journée festive familiale conviviale
l'idée était vraiment de faire proposer
aux habitants de sud yvelines
voilà au tour de rais m'bohi mais aussi
autour de belles mais aussi autour de
gambe et fait vraiment vu tous nos
publics différents pour un seul
événement et puis fêter le printemps
arrive et puis fêter aussi cet endroit
cet endroit magnifique qui est assez
propice à l'organisation de d'événements
qui rassemble et donc vous avez parlé
des trois centres qui participe du coup
a créé cet événement pourquoi s'allier
pour créer justement cette journée est
en fait il ya eu une envie commune de
mutualiser nos moyens mutualisés nos
équipes d'apprendre aussi à se connaître
parce qu'en fait on a des enjeux des
objectifs qui se rejoignent faire vivre
la culture l'art dans ce territoire du
sud-yvelines particulièrement qui est un
territoire
particulier la fois proche de permis à
la femme paris
du coup du coup c'est comment faire
vivre aussi ses initiatives artistiques
et culturelles comme
dans le village les petites communes du
sud yvelines comme des commandes
vous voyez
ces rôles de compte qu'on avait aussi
les trois structures des choses à
proposer à s'apprendre créer du lien
entre trois structures qui sont qui sont
assez espacés quand même dans le
territoire et ça permet de mutualiser
les moyens et elle est aussi les moyens
artistiques et les propositions
artistiques et du coup chaque fanfare
faire des résidences dans chacune des
structures proposées les actions
culturelles et
et du coup final créer du lien entre
entre les structures culturelles et
aussi entre
les générations et etc lors de
l'événement donc il y aura quatre
fanfares qui vont se produire tour à
tour gipsy pigs oméga aux bandes et la
fanfare de lusine on va regarder un
petit extrait si vous le voulez bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous présenter
un petit peu les quatre fanfares tv en
premier c'est la fanfare de l usine qui
va ouvrir l'événement qui comme son nom
l'indiqué est une fanfare qui répète à
l'usiné à chapeaux depuis depuis bien
des années et qui mêle dans son
répertoire à la fois des reprises de
variétés françaises
des choses plus traditionnels aussi du
funk du ska
et voilà qu'ils qui animent souvent des
événements associatifs culturels ou
sportifs dans l'embrouillé et ses
alentours
ensuite dans le programme il ya l'egypte
sipix l'egypte sipix nous propose un
vraiment un spectacle un spectacle
musical les fêtes du grand là bas ces
huit musiciens qui nous viennent de
normandie et qui
l'histoire du spectacle c'est ils
racontent leur pays imaginaire le pix
jouanno et c'est un spectacle qui régale
absolument les petits et les grands
c'est très humoristique et ils sont très
forts ensuite c'est la fanfare oméga qui
est venu comme les gypsies pigs
plusieurs fois en résidence au lieu
répétées et la fanfare oméga c'est une
fanfare très festive aussi qui joue avec
vraiment des orientations musicales que
klezmer ou tzigane et ça fait danser
vraiment
est donc la quatrième fanfare c'est le
uss bande qui ne fanfaronnait zh et qui
est venu en résidence à l'usiné à
chapeaux et
pareil qui sont dans un esprit très
dansant et qui sont en train de mettre
au point leur prochain
leur prochain spectacle qui s'appelle
singer qui est plutôt avec des notes un
peu électro et par rapport à l'or par
rapport à leurs spectacles de rue qui
sape le sepa louzier mct et
et donc voilà ils auront l'occasion de
présenter les deux
le jour de l'événement donc c'est des
fanfares qui viennent de tout horizon
pas forcément d y viennent justement on
accueille des fanfares de toute la
france donc la seule fanfare yvelinoise
c'est la fanfare de lusine qui vient
donc de rendre et c'est la seule font
forts amateurs d'ailleurs c'était
important de la faire venir justement
d'avoir une petite fanfare yvelinoise
ici oui c'est important mais ça fait
partie cette partie des démissions ça
fait partie de dés
des volontés de l' usine à chapeaux de
proposer des artistes locaux aussi et je
pense que c'est important aussi d'en
créer eux
en plus des structures d'encre est
vraiment une proposition artistique
locale dans l'événement et du coup
pourquoi avoir décidé d'avoir je demande
quatre fanfares au lieu d'une et
pourquoi spécifiquement celle ci du coup
alors en fait le choix dès le choix des
fanfares c'est fait l'année dernière ça
a été un choix mais de chacune des
structures on avait bon on avait envie
de travailler avec ces équipes
artistiques qu'on avait soient
rencontrés parce qu'ils étaient déjà
venus en résidence dans une de nos
structures soit qu'on avait croisé en
festivals etc
donc on en a accueilli tout au long de
l'année en fait on a accueilli d'autres
fanfares notamment la compagnie du coin
qui est venu plusieurs fois à benne et à
gan b et puis et voilà les toutes les
fanfares sont peu sont vraiment passées
on fait des spectacles préalables
notamment cet automne dans différentes
communes et puis là on avait un on avait
un créneau quand même qui nous permet
péter pas non plus d'accueillir 10
fanfare mais mes quatre en tout cas ça
allait bien dans dans la temporalité de
la journée mais qu'est ce qu'ils vont
jouer comme morceau je sais que par
exemple la fanfare de l'usiné fait
principalement des reprises du coup
qu'est ce que quel style ils vont jouer
je pense que l'événement va être plutôt
festif et dansant donc quoi qu'il en
soit de toute façon ça va être
je pense que je pense que tout le monde
a en tête quelque chose depuis suez 2 et
pour pour faire danser les plus petits
jusqu'aux plus gros au cours de la
journée alors du coup dans le votre
programme vous avez aussi des balades
musicales improvisées est ce que
pouvaient un petit peu m'expliquer ce
que c'est oui les balades musicales
improvisées en fait l'idée c'était de
pouvoir aussi
proposé au public de sortir de la base
de loisirs pour profiter un peu plus
largement de cet espace qui est bien
plus vaste et on a inventé un une petite
forme qui sera comme son nom l'indiqué
assez improvisé qui va jouer sur le
hasard parce qu'on va proposer à des
personnes du public de pioche est le nom
d'un musicien ou d'une musicienne le nom
d'un comédien ou d'une comédienne et un
texte est ensuite
ces personnes vont partir avec une
petite jauge de public nous vingtaine
trentaine de personnes selon selon les
personnes qui selon de public et ils
vont partir pour faire le tour de
l'étang avec voilà le musicien et le
comédien vont devoir s'accorder pour
inventer une forme une balade artistique
est elle proposée aux spectateurs alors
du coup les musiciens qui font ce qu'ils
vont faire ces balades artistiques c'est
les musiciens qu'on retrouve dans les
fanfares et les comédiens et comédiennes
c'est déco et bien et des comédiennes de
la jeune troupe de l'atalante qui est
une une troupe située à à paris c'est
des futurs professionnels comédiens
voilà qu'ils viennent régulièrement
aussi travaillé au lieu chaque année on
aime beaucoup et on est très très
heureux de pouvoir les accueillir aussi
sur sur ce genre de proposition et donc
pour les yvelinois du coc qui ne
connaissent pas les étangs de hollande
ce sont six étangs qui ont été aménagés
à l'époque de louis xiv pour alimenter
les grandes eaux de versailles c'est
maintenant un super lieu pour les
sorties et les activités pourquoi avoir
choisi de le faire ici mais parce que je
pense que c'est bien représentatifs du
patrimoine naturel qu'on a dans les îles
line est d'une
richesse dans les paysages c'est un
cadre assez
assez incroyable pour faire un événement
en fait et
c'est l'occasion aussi bon comme on l'a
dit faire une
balade autour de l'étang et et
et ça ça je trouve que ça colle bien
avec avec l'événement qu'on propose est
géographiquement c'est un lieu qui
voilà qui se situe entre les trois
structures aussi donc ça c'était
important de ne pas faire un ne pas
trouver un endroit qui était trop
excentré et du coup on a été soutenue
pour faire cet événement normalement par
la commune des bréviaires et puis par la
communauté d'agglomération de
rambouillet territoire qui nous
permettre d'avoir accès à la base de
loisirs et à l'ensemble du site et puis
on est soutenus pour ce projet par la
région ile-de-france donc sur place
qu'est ce qu'on pourra retrouver ce qui
aura une buvette un fou de trek il y
aura il y aura un food truck oui
car hot n' roll qui propose notamment
des wraps végétarien avec pas mal
d'influx ans dans la cuisine asiatique
il y aura une buvette évidemment parce
qu'on peut pas faire un événement phare
sans budget
et donc pour les informations pratiques
ces entrées libres c'est ça c'est pour
tout le monde oui et c'est entre keller
et keller 15h et voter une petit dernier
mot peut-être pour donner envie aux gens
de venir eh bien on est très très très
pressé de pouvoir vous retrouver vous
accueillir et puis on est on est des
équipes de trois structures différentes
avec voilà vraiment dans les starting
blocks avec hâte de rencontrer
de rencontrer tout public et les
spectateurs qui vont découvrir nos
fanfare et peut-être découvrir ou
redécouvrir ce lieu comme ils ne l'ont
jamais vu mais voilà on espère que c'est
un événement qui va en plus de créer du
lien entre trois structures différentes
crée du lien entre des artistes de
compagnies différentes et du public de
différents horizons horizon des idéaux
non merci sidonie et l'yonne coup nous
avoir parlé de cet événement vous pouvez
donc retrouver ses quatre fanfares le
samedi 21 mai ici même aux étangs de
hollande à partir de 15 heures on espère
vous retrouver là-bas bonne journée à
tous
[Musique]
et